today the matte wall show the media is
warning about a dangerous and perverse
new trend that has taken over Tick Tock
it's called being a stay-at-home mom
very scary stuff at least as far as the
left is concerned also journalists have
managed to dig up some shocking dirt on
Ron DeSantis turns out that he has bad
table manners which is a big deal I
guess plus our UFOs landing on military
bases and using their alien energy to
give people traumatic brain injuries the
answer is yes they are but we'll talk
about it in our daily cancellation we
will tackle what may ultimately go down
as the dumbest internet outrage of the
Year all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh
[Music]
okay
you know companies aren't just selling
products anymore they're selling you
tech companies enrich themselves by
selling your personal data they grab
your web history they're they're they
email metadata video searches to create
a detailed profile on you and then sell
it off to the highest bidder when you go
online without a VPN internet service
providers can see every single website
you visit they can legally sell this
information without your consent of
course to ad companies and Tech Giants
who will then use it to Target you
that's why to keep my data private when
I go online I use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes my connection through an
encrypted server which makes it more
difficult for third parties to find me
sounds complicated but really on your
end it's really simple you just tap one
button and you're good to go if like me
you believe that your data is your
business secure your yourself with the
number one rated VPN on the market visit
expressvpn.com Walsh and get three extra
months for free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Welsh to
learn more
recently our cultural authority figures
the people who decide what we're
supposed to think and what we're
supposed to do and what our values and
goals and aspirations are supposed to be
have become very alarmed by a perverse
and dangerous new trend among young
women in particular
of course um I'm not talking about the
trend where young women have their
breasts removed and then start injecting
themselves with testosterone so that
their hair falls out and they grow
beards and they become infertile The
Gatekeepers are not concerned about that
Trend at all if anything they're worried
that the trend isn't even more popular
than it already is
no instead they're deeply worried about
women who choose the so-called Trad wife
lifestyle over the past couple of years
a growing number of women have started
posting Tick Tock videos describing and
documenting their day-to-day existence
as Trad wives quote unquote what is a
Trad wife well she is a woman who stays
home to take care of the house takes
care of the children while her husband
goes to work she does most of the
cooking and the cleaning she handles the
Lion's Share of the domestic labor while
relying on her husband to be the
provider in breadwinner in other words
she is uh just a normal woman doing what
many millions of other normal women have
done before her
which is why my only objection really to
the Trad wife trend is that we're
calling it a trend and we're giving it a
cutesy name and a hashtag that's my only
problem with it my wife would fit the
description of a quote-unquote Trad wife
but not because she's taking part in a
Tick-Tock Trend we've been living this
way for 10 years and I wouldn't really
call it a lifestyle either but rather a
system
that works for us just as it has worked
for the majority of families all over
the world since the dawn of human
civilization even before the Industrial
Age and the Advent of the modern nine to
five job
um you know before that you the phrase
or the term stay-at-home mom didn't
didn't exist still even then most
families featured a man who would go out
whether to the fields to farm or the
forest to hunt or later to the office to
earn a paycheck and a woman who stays in
the home to care for the children
there's a very standard arrangement
the women on Tick Tock aren't inventing
a trend but rather they're partaking in
a way of life that is ancient and
enduring and battle tested
but that's not how the left sees it as
an article on foxnews.com reports quote
donning elaborate dresses fascinating an
apron around their waist and popping in
their finest pearl earrings or at least
some iteration of pearls for another
round of household chores or cooking
more and more young women are following
in the footsteps of the quintessential
mid-century housewife thanks to the
latest Tick-Tock Trend but while some
women are eager to shirk all the hustle
and bustle of today's corporate world
and channel Barbara Billingsley as June
Cleaver others are none too happy with
the trend quote the new trend for
submissive women has a dark heart in
history reads one headline from the
guardian an article from hype Bay
slapped the videos as disturbing writing
that they quote typically feature a CIS
strike CIS straight white woman longing
for the 50s an era where some women
could opt out of participating in the
corporate working world and be
stay-at-home mothers instead and a third
from grazia magazine accused the trend
of quote romanticizing an era where
sexism and racism ruled
we can also add a recent CNN article
which calls Trad wives otherwise known
as Housewives or stay-at-home moms a
quote Fringe subculture
meanwhile a piece by Insider says that
many of these women are promoting white
supremacist views
this was the argument made this week in
a video by a left-wing media
organization called Novara media a woman
named Ash sakhar argues that Trad wives
are really just agents of a far-right
political agenda here she is
though the idea of women being confined
to the home while men do things like go
outside and work isn't exactly new the
image of 1950s Suburban Domesticity has
been given a new lease of Life by the
gals on Tick Tock can you imagine me the
wife of that foolish brainless
some younger Millennials and Zoomers
have decided to embrace living la Vida
casserole dedicating themselves to
cooking cleaning and child rearing while
their husbands or boyfriends I don't
know chop firewood or go to their job in
human resources and look I'm not saying
there's anything inherently degrading
about being a mom or making nice meals I
like cooking elaborate dinners for that
matter my boyfriend does too but the
Trad wife Trend isn't just a way to talk
about the experience of being a woman
and doing domestic labor
it's saying that being a woman or
expressing your femininity most fully
means doing all the domestic labor men
and women are meant to have rigidly
distinct roles in the home in their
relationships and crucially in economic
activity so this isn't just about
personal choice or individual
preferences it's advancing a right-wing
political ideology and dressing it up as
a lifestyle
so why is this important three things
these women are often really young in
their 20s and they're preaching the
values of submitting to a husband to an
audience of other young women the Trad
wife Trend doesn't exist in isolation
it's linked to deeply regressive
political and social movements such as
Christian and white nationalism and
anti-feminism feminism is an ideology
which cannot be defended by feminists
it's part of a wider shift of young
people being dissatisfied with
neoliberalism and wanting social change
well she's right about that last Point
not not any of the rest of it but the
last Point anyway but before we flesh
that out uh let's consider a few other
points first you see how stigmatization
is perhaps the left's most common and
useful tool always has been I mean even
even as they claim that they want people
to be free to live their lives without
judgment the truth is that they have a
very rigid idea about what sorts of
Lifestyle should be embraced
and the standard is very simple actually
it's not complicated we should celebrate
any and all Lifestyles that would not be
traditionally considered normal okay
that's the one rule so live how you want
just don't be normal
that's why they use a term like Fringe
subculture to describe a housewife in an
apron who would uh you know but they
would never put such a label on a a man
and a wig and a skirt standing up to pee
in the women's restroom he's not part of
a fringe subculture
instead a 25 year old woman with two
kids and a husband baking a casserole
she's The Fringe weirdo the the
degenerate pervert
now if that same woman was doing all the
same things but happened to actually be
a man then she or he in this case would
be revered as a bold and powerful woman
daring to live her life as she wishes
the problem with the actual real woman
living this way is that she again is
normal and while they shame normalcy as
perverse and they treat perversion as
normal they somehow have succeeded in
convincing many conservatives to not
respond in kind
as we should
so they will openly call stay-at-home
moms a fringe subculture while insisting
that we must never use such language to
describe Lifestyles that are actually
degenerate
and again many conservatives willingly
play along
by with this they willingly play by this
rule the left accuses the Trad wife of
engaging in a political Act
but the truth is that you know what
they're really angry about is they're
angry
that she isn't engaging in a political
Act
she's simply living in a way that is
healthy and traditional and she's
prioritizing her family
she she is not turning her entire
existence into a political statement she
is focused on things deeper and more
meaningful than that and that is what
infuriates them
remember that these are people who've
structured their whole lives around
opposing Traditional Values they they're
not even pursuing happiness or
fulfillment or meaning they'll settle
for misery so long as their misery is a
protest against the value systems they
despise
except that ultimately their misery only
confirms and supports that very same
value system
and that's where the woman in the video
had it right I think um people are
deeply dissatisfied with the life that
leftism has given them these uh
so-called Trad wives they grew up in a
society that told them that men and
women are the same uh that we ought to
have exactly identical roles in society
that it's demeaning it's oppressive to
prioritize raising children and caring
for your family that fulfillment is
found in serving your boss rather than
your spouse that a strong an independent
woman is one who depends on her employer
rather than her husband
they were raised in a culture that takes
all of these ideas for granted
they were socialized and conditioned to
accept them as gospel truth and many of
them did for a Time
and then discovered that it was all a
lie
you know the most basic problem with
leftism is that it is just Hollow at its
core
it doesn't have an answer or at least
not a satisfying answer
to the question of of why we're here on
this Earth and what we're supposed to be
doing with our time
this um
ambiguity this lack of answers is
presented to us as freedom
but it's the freedom of being lost in
the woods the freedom of having no idea
where to go or why
that's not Freedom that's abandonment
this is what has happened so multiple
generations of Americans they've been
brought down a path with uh Promises of
happiness and fulfillment around the
corner and then they were just left
there abandoned
this is this is the the source of much
of the uh you know the epidemic of
Despair what we now call depression in
our society it stems from this not from
Mental Illness but from this
that you have generated millions of
Americans that were LED down a path they
said well come this way don't go that
way okay that's the way that all of your
ancestors went that's the way that
people for for uh for thousands of years
went uh don't go that way come this way
instead
and all these people listen they said
okay I'll go that way
and then one day they looked around they
said well where are we exactly what's
the point of this where were you taking
us
we're just lost here now we're stuck
so the people who are returning to
traditional Lives who are making the
radical decision to focus on their
families and their marriages and and so
on
um these are people simply deciding to
live with some sense of direction
to live with meaning
okay that's what they're doing they're
not making some white supremacist
radical political statement they are
reclaiming meaning in their lives
and they are certainly happier for it
now let's get to our five headlines
people are raving about genucel skin
care Sherry from Omaha Nebraska says I
have sensitive skin and I'm careful
about all my products my husband bought
me genucel bags and puffiness and
genocell deep Firming Serum I felt it
working immediately my eyes look amazing
my face smells feels smooth and wrinkle
free well it's not just Sherry genucel
sold over 1 million products uh a box of
which I have right here in front of me
and they sell these to both women and
men Across the Nation you could say
goodbye to Fine Lines wrinkles and even
those annoying under eye bags geniusell
will have you looking 5 10 even 15 years
younger just in time for warmer weather
best of all genucel guarantees results
in as little as uh 12 hours or your
money back you know my producer Sean
uses geniusell's probiotic moisturizer
daily
to help keep his bald head shiny and
smooth before his vacation next week
that's a little anecdote that you needed
to hear try it for yourself okay
genucel's most popular package including
their classic under eye bags and
puffiness treatment for 70 off at
genucel.com Walsh you get free shipping
plus a luxury Beauty Box containing two
free gifts with every subscription if
you want to get that you have to go to
genucel.com Welsh
well one thing is clear it's been clear
for a long time the media is terrified
of Ron DeSantis and of his candidacy his
potential candidacy for president
um ultimately they hate DeSantis more
than they hate Trump and I you know I've
been saying that for for a while and the
reason is that they recognize that Ron
DeSantis is effective at wielding state
power to advance a conservative agenda
okay he's done that in Florida he's able
to do that he's willing to do he knows
how to do it
um that's something that Trump never
learned how to do
he didn't
um and so Ron DeSantis is a greater
threat to them
and that's also why we've seen the
personal hit pieces and the Rumor
mongering pickup steam recently
um it's uh but but it turns out that
Rhonda Sanchez is I guess squeaky clean
and his closets are free of all
skeletons because the stuff they're
coming up with to hit him with it's it's
um well it's not exactly
earth-shattering we could say that
and most of it just makes me like him
even more so for example
a few days ago reports were circulating
that Ron DeSantis
um wasn't because he was in Congress of
course before he became uh governor of
Florida and reports were circulating
that he wasn't well liked by his
Republican colleagues when he was in
Congress and he didn't make a lot of
friends and he wasn't invited to the
parties and he didn't hang out with them
he was kind of a loner he was on his own
uh there was there was one quote saying
he didn't seem to like being in DC he
didn't even want to be there
and this is supposed to make us like him
less somehow which I'm trying to figure
out how that works because that's
exactly what I want to hear the last
thing I want to hear is that um
is that someone who loves being in DC
loves the environment it's making tons
of friends
that's who we don't want in the White
House
so that just makes me like him more and
then there's this from media this is the
latest this was the big uh expose that
was published yesterday
not by media but by The Daily Beast and
they are reporting on that a new report
on Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
provided further detail on his
well-documented struggles with personal
public engagement a quirk that
reportedly includes unorthodox table
manners a new Daily Beast report on
DeSantis which comes amid ongoing
speculation about 2024 Ambitions tackled
concerns about his aloof Persona
aversion to public interactions and the
distance he keeps from voters and
reporters alike
the reporting on the governor's
personality and social graces delved
into unflattering stories that the Beast
uncovered about him from over the years
namely his propensity to devour food
during meetings
from the article quote he would sit in
meetings and eat in front of people a
former DeSantis staffer told The Daily
Beast always like a starving animal
who's never eaten before getting
everywhere
I assume they mean getting food
everywhere not literally getting
everywhere
um I mean if that was happening then I
would agree that it's a problem
enshrined into Santa's lore is an
episode from four years ago during a
private plane trip from Tallahassee to
Washington DC in March 2019. the sand
has enjoyed a chocolate pudding dessert
by eating it with three of his fingers
according to two sources familiar with
the incident representative ferdinand's
political team did not return a request
for comment on it
I can't imagine why not
they have reporters beating down their
door asking for comment on a report that
he ate pudding with his fingers
I'm surprised you know well this is the
kind of thing we need to uh we need a an
official public statement we need a
press conference
we need all of that
so they actually talked to two sources
multiple sources to confirm that four
years ago Ron DeSantis ate pudding with
his fingers and this is what they come
up with
and this is the like we can assume right
we can assume that if they had better
stuff than this they'd be telling us
they've been they've been uh digging
through his personal life they've been
talking anyone will talk to them they've
been interviewing sources okay they're
looking for juicy material about this
guy and the best they can do is that he
has bad table manners
and that he's he's not a people person
doesn't make a lot of friends
now as far as eating pudding with your
fingers
um
you know I
most of the time I would agree that's
that is that's uncouth
but also
what else are you supposed to do
if you don't have a spoon and that's
some of the detail if you're gonna have
this whole report about how he eats
pudding then I think we need more
details about why was he even putting
with me what was there a spoon or some
other utensil available on the flight
and if there wasn't then what else are
you supposed to do I ask you this
okay you're in a situation where you
have putting you know maybe someone
hands you chocolate pudding you ask for
a spoon and they tell you we don't have
a spoon and you say well you do you at
least have a fork I could maybe make
that work they say we don't have a fork
what are you gonna do in that situation
are you gonna not eat the pudding are
you gonna say to yourself oh I have this
delicious pudding here I'm just not
gonna eat it
I mean give me a break let's be serious
about this
and uh in a situation like that
you do what you have to do
what you know what this tells me this
tells me that that Ron DeSantis is a man
who's not afraid to get his hands dirty
uh not afraid to do what needs to be
done in the moment to get the job done
and that's what I like about them
is that he gets the job done
you work with what you have
and you make it happen
and that's what he did with his pudding
and so I see it as uh uh really a
microcosm of what makes him an effective
governor in the first place I would
argue
all the rest of it I don't care look
this this whole thing they've been doing
this for years
where they um
they want the litmus test for a
politician a president to be would you
want to sit down and have a beer with
this person would you want to be there
friend I don't give
crap about that I don't need to feel
like now it just so happens that I think
I could sit down and have a beer with
Ron DeSantis and enjoy conversation with
him but
um but who cares that I don't need to
feel like what are we a bunch of
children okay don't answer that because
many voters that is how we we Act
or a bunch of children we need to we
need to feel like someone running for
president can be our friend would he be
my friend who cares
so he doesn't make friends he's not a
personable per
why does that matter I don't need that I
don't need you to be friendly I don't
need you to make friends
um I don't need you to be a fun guy to
hang out with because I'm not hanging
out with you I need you to know how to
govern
and I need you to understand how to
wield power effectively and in the right
way for the right ends that's what I
need
and you know what it turns out that that
many of the people
who fall into that category
are you know effective leaders they know
how to wield power
um all those kinds of things
like often oftentimes that they're not
the most fun to hang out with
it's like a certain it's a certain
personality type A Certain sort of
person
is good in that role
and often it's not the kind of person
that you would want to like
sit down and have a beer with
sometimes the two line up but it doesn't
matter if they do
um so what do we learn from this all we
learn is just make sure that like just
make sure Rhonda Santos has a spoon on
hand that's all
I'm pretty sure there are many spoons in
the white house so if you're worried
about this if you're worried about
having a uh a a a man in the white house
so he's pudding with his fingers just
remember that they have spoons in the
white house I think I'm pretty sure they
probably have a lot of them so this this
should not be
in a fence that's repeated
um well it comes to the current
occupants of the white house if you want
to know how stupid they are uh here's a
here's a good example
last week the House and Senate both
unanimously passed a bill to declassify
all the intelligence around the origins
of covet
and this was a unanimous housing Senate
it was Zero no votes um I think there
were a couple people that were voted
absent or you know not present but uh it
was there was no it was it was a nope
nobody voted against it unanimous vote
and I usually say that bipartisan bills
are the worst kinds of bills because
legislation has to be pretty uniquely
terrible to attract the support of both
parties
but there are exceptions to every Rule
and so this is one obviously they should
declassify whatever information they
have
even if they do declassify it I'm not
going to believe that they really
Declassified all of it but
still in theory this is the right thing
to do obviously
um now I'm not going to give them much
credit for voting for this they all have
re-elections or most of them have
re-elections that they have to worry
about they don't want to be on the
record as being in the minority opposed
to transparency when it comes to the
origins of covet so they really had no
choice but to vote in favor of it
um
and they all did legislation goes to
Biden's desk
a week later he still has not signed it
or even decided what he's going to do
with it and Karen Jean pair was asked
about this at the White House yesterday
let's hear what she said
I wondered if you do have an answer now
as to whether or not the president will
sign the covet Origins intelligence
so it's so we are thank you for the
question I know I was asked about it I
believe on the plane uh on Monday as you
just mentioned so we're looking at it uh
we have continued to share information
with members of Congress and as you know
just months after the president came
into office he uh asked his intelligence
Community uh to double down and to take
a look of the of uh the origins of the
covet Origins because we believe it's
important to get to the bottom of this
and to get and also if once we have uh
once the intelligence Community has made
the made the assessments clearly we
would share that with the public as it
relates to the legislation we're going
to continue to we're going to take a
look at it and certainly we'll have more
to share we haven't made a decision
whether no we're just taking a look
we're taking a look into the into the
bill
just taking a look at it this is this is
uh it should be an easy slam dunk you
know it's like you need to spend
uh first of all they pass and sign
legislation all the time without reading
it so since when do they care about that
this should be I don't know think about
it for half an hour and then sign it
there's nothing really to think about
yes obviously the the public has the
right to know everything there is to
know about the origins of covet but also
from a political perspective
you don't have a choice this is
unanimous
it takes two-thirds of a vote um it's a
two-third vote to override a
presidential veto so even if he did make
the politically suicidal decision to
veto it it's going to happen anyway
so you might as well just take the win
even if Biden would prefer not to
declassify because he doesn't want to
upset China
um you have no choice so you might as
well say well yes absolutely of course
we're going to sign this right away
we give this Administration cares deeply
about transparency
that's going to be the result anyway so
you from a political perspective you
take ownership of it and pretend that
it's what you wanted to do
but these people are so stupid they
don't even understand that
I don't know why I'm giving political
advice to the Bible Administration not
that they'll listen to it anyway
um
all right
we'll go here in Kentucky representative
Jerry Miller is a former Republican now
Democrat and he testified against a bill
that would ban gender transitions for
minors and here's the um the story that
he told to explain his position
as a grandfather of two girls I was
thrilled to learn my daughter was
pregnant with a boy I thought of all the
things we would do together like playing
ball that's just not been my reality as
a toddler he wasn't interested in balls
he has she has
focused on dolls not balls he started
dressing a girl like a girl mainly
princess dresses at age
three at home uh my his mother tried to
dissuade him from doing so at age four
my intuitive wife asked the dress chair
wearing child if he didn't like being a
boy his response was quote inside I feel
like a girl close quote
my wife accepted that Jonah was
different well before I did I thought it
was because he had an older sister that
he was competing with
I hoped he would grow out of it but that
has not happened I still screw up the
pronoun thing but regardless if anything
I'm going to love my grandchild
and fight for what I think is best for
Jonah for that reason
I urge you to vote against that Kentucky
Constitution
uh says that we should seek uh section
one says we are able to seek and pursue
safety and happiness and I ask you where
is Kentucky's compelling government
interest
um in not letting a parent protect their
own children's safety and happiness
what a pathetic excuse for a man
I mean it's no wonder he supports
castration this is a castrated man
himself
uh
whether literally I don't know but
certainly metaphorically
just a completely ballless pathetic
nothing of a man sitting there saying
I'm gonna love my grandchild no you
don't love him actually you do not love
him
you might tell yourself that you do but
you don't
um there are things that you love a lot
more than your grandchild going along
with the culture uh taking a politically
popular position you know those things
you value a lot more than you do your
grandson
because if you loved your grandson you
would fight for
for him and for his well-being
and you would uh you would do everything
you can to protect him from the abuse
that he is being subjected to right now
and we we hear the this it's all it's
always the same story it is always some
of the times that we heard these stories
it's always the same story
okay all we we've a million times we
hear the story about the uh the child a
very young child who quote unquote comes
out as trans or reveals their true
identity
uh supposedly
and we we never hear
like you never hear anything that it
kind of blows your mind and is in and
makes you go oh well wow you know maybe
that person maybe that boy really uh
maybe it really is a girl stuck in a
boy's body well I've never heard of
anything like that you never hear any
detail I don't know what that detail
would even sound like I mean really
there's nothing you could say that would
that would make me accept the
proposition that a boy is really a girl
because that's a a logical contradiction
doesn't make any sense there's no way to
accept it
but my point is that
the story that they tell it's always
just oh it was a boy and he liked to
wear dresses when he was two years old
and that's what persuades you that um we
need to radically alter the very course
of that's what persuades you that
something that's what persuades you that
that everything you thought you knew
about reality itself is wrong because
that's what he's actually telling us
what he's telling us is that it turns
out that this boy who's a boy in every
way is really a girl somehow can't
explain that they never explain that
they never try to explain that
but in order to accept that you would
have to first abandon everything you
thought you knew about reality about
biology about everything everything out
the window
and what caused you
to radically and fundamentally alter
your very perception of reality that a
two-year-old boy put a dress on because
he was allowed to by his parents that a
two-year-old boy thought that a sparkly
thing was pretty
what caused you to well maybe everything
I think about the world is wrong it
turns out
um
but I just don't I don't believe that
that he's that stupid
and maybe people are you know maybe I
I've maybe I have severely overestimated
the intelligence of most people
but when I hear stories like that I
think there's no way the guy is that
stupid he cannot be that stupid
now he's going along he he knows better
but he's going along with it which makes
it even worse
all right
um this video is making the rounds it's
actually from several years ago and it's
from an episode of uh The Price is Right
and there's a certain contestant
appeared on this show a few years ago
and you may recognize him
let's watch
spin the wheel they get to spin the
wheel but guess what you get a second
chance in this game first
so you know two prices already which is
a great thing 399 and 5.99 which one do
you want to keep
I'm going to keep the 5.99 keep 5.99
something else up here is 5.99 you can
tell me what it is you get everything
I'm gonna say the soup
5.99 it's pretty fancy it is
yes you got it that was the winner still
is a winner Dylan nice job man
look at that uh we're gonna spin the
wheel right after this don't go away
folks
[Music]
my God foreign
the father
imagine being a dad
and you're told that you know your son's
gonna be on Price is Right
and you sit down and you have a beer and
you sit down to watch more price is
right and this is what you see
imagine seeing your son
[Applause]
I don't know how you go I don't know how
you
move on after that
well
but of course still all right turn off
please turn
uh
of course if Dylan Mulvaney's father
thought that this was the worst
embarrassment he was ever going to
suffer he was in for a rude awakening as
time goes on now the point here though
is that was a couple things
first of all this guy's been starved for
attention you know for a long time uh
has been uh begging for attention that's
what that's what all this is about
anyway but also
his
you note how his performance
as a woman
his performance as a woman as a woman is
identical to his performance as a
flamboyant homosexual on Price is Right
and this is a performance as well
because like no no human being actually
acts like that in real life so this is a
before it's like it's a it's an affect
that he's putting on
um but it's exactly the same
because that's all that a woman is to
the left that's the left's vision of
Womanhood that's all a woman is a woman
is a flamboyant gay man in a dress
so you've got flamboyant gay man and
then you and then you take that same
flamboyant gay man change nothing about
him
put a dress on him that's a woman
that is truly how they see it
um okay we're uh
moving on quickly because there's
several other things we need to talk
about including okay we're gonna get
right to this because this is the most
important and if I don't mention now I
might not have time for it
um
we'll start with the New York Post
Pentagon officials said in a draft
document last week that aliens could be
visiting our solar system and releasing
smaller probes
um uh with our missions that are
conducted
releasing smaller probes like missions
conducted by NASA when studying other
planets
uh a draft research report author by
Sean Kirkpatrick the director of the
pentagon's all domain anomaly resolution
office and Abraham Loeb chairman of the
Harvard University's astronomy
Department was released on March 7th and
focuses on the physical constraints of
unidentified aerial phenomena
the report read quote an artificial
Interstellar object could potentially be
a parent craft that releases many small
probes during its close passage to Earth
an operational construct not too
dissimilar from NASA missions these
dandelion seeds could be separated from
the parent craft by the tidal
gravitational force of the Sun or by a
maneuvering capability
the aaro was published in July 20 2022
and is responsible for tracking objects
in the sky underwater and in space or
possibly an object that has the ability
to move from one domain to the next
Congress tasked NASA to find 90 of all
objects near Earth that are larger than
140 meters in 2005 which resulted in pan
Stars telescopes according to the report
on October 19 2017 the pan Stars
detected an unusual Interstellar object
that was later named never know how to
pronounce this or any other word uh um
we'll just call it o or uh or Scout in
Hawaii okay we'll call it Scout the
object was cigar shaped appeared flat
and was propelled away from the Sun
without showing a cometary tale leading
scientists to believe it was artificial
so this was um
yes and then there are images you can
see of this but it's uh just a long
flight it looks like a long it looks
like a cigar it looks like a long flat
object that uh we know is Interstellar
and there are some scientists who think
that it might be they don't know exactly
but it might be artificial it might be
some kind of uh you know alien
technology it could be a piece of
something that broke off who knows
but this is what scientists are now
speculating about that maybe
and this would explain uh some of what
we see in the skies some of what
military Pilots have seen the Navy
Pilots
um where you've got these small which
seem to be vehicles that are moving
around in odd ways and they don't seem
to be propelled but there's no
propulsion device that we can see that's
noticeable to us and so maybe these are
probes that are being sent from a larger
craft sent down to check out Earth and
then they go back to the parent craft
and uh go on their way
it's possible Theory but you have
scientists who are speculating about
this meanwhile Tucker Carlson was
recently on a podcast and had a really
interesting conversation about UFOs the
whole conversation is 10 minutes long
and I debated playing the entire thing
on the show but uh I thought that might
be pressing it a little bit so instead
we have still kind of long about two and
a half minutes but it's an interesting
story
um
and with a little bit of a first-hand
account here from Taco Carlson uh I just
go ahead and listen depending on was
required by the last defense
authorization Bill to like produce some
of their files on UFOs and it turns out
they have known about this since the end
of the second world war which ended in
1945 been a huge increase during that
war during the war as well
a huge increase in UFO sightings in UFO
crashes
etc etc and it turns out the federal
government has been tracking this for 80
years and lying about it so why well
that's a great question I can't answer
it of theories but I don't know but
here's what I learned
just to the first question is is this
real or am I just being a crazy person
who's spending too much time on the
internet well this summer
we got a call we didn't reach out this
person called us Lexi who's standing
right there who's a genius one of our
producers gets his call from this guy
who's a tenured Stanford Medical School
professor and he wants to come on the
show now this guy has a couple patents
and so he's rich and he's got tenure at
one of the most prestigious schools in
the world so like he's not a flake
he comes on and he's like 11 years ago
the US government reached out to me
because I'm an expert on head injuries
on brain injuries traumatic brain
injuries as a physician and they had all
these court cases from families of U.S
servicemen over a hundred who'd been
killed by UFOs
and the Department of Defense was
refusing to give them death benefits or
medical benefits
and I'm like and he's like so they're in
the courts and I was like there are over
a hundred servicemen killed by UFOs like
what
he's like yeah and there are court cases
about it I'm like why isn't this on the
front page of the New York Times I don't
know but he goes I'm involved in I'm the
you know I'm one of the researchers I'm
the expert witness in these cases holy
what does that mean and he's like
for example UFOs appear to be attracted
for whatever reason to nuclear energy
so at nuclear missile bases in the Upper
Midwest for example nuclear-powered
aircraft carriers nuclear-powered
submarines are all getting buzzed by
these objects including underwater
and in a number of cases these things
have landed on military bases including
famously in Germany in West Germany in
the 70s and servicemen have approached
them like what is this thing there's
this like giant glowing thing on the
base and they approach and they get
traumatic brain injury
like they are rendered
yeah yeah they get brain damage or
they're killed and he studied their
brains
and they have this is all totally real
this is not this is the Department of
Defense dude
and they've all had this damage from
some kind of powerful energy that we
cannot identify
there it is I mean uh like I said the
whole conversation is interesting it's
about 10 minutes long and he goes into
uh talking about how
you know most the people that have
looked at this
have uh think that that many of these
objects actually are coming
um not from the sky but coming out of
the ocean and that that has also been
observed you know sounds crazy but
that's we there's there's actually video
of that that has also been captured by
pilots and uh and other kinds of videos
where you can see things there's video
where you've got objects that come out
of the ocean and then go fly with this
guy also video of objects going into the
ocean at high rates of speed and not
exploding
contact
um
so look
what are you gonna do with this it's
there's there is a lot of evidence here
and I know we joke about it a little bit
but that's that's the truth there's a
lot of evidence
um now is it enough to absolutely
confirm that uh that
some sort of beings from another
solar system or Galaxy of visited Earth
no because there's a lot of details that
we don't have but even so I mean when
you when you start thinking about well
if it were true
that there were uh you know the
intelligent civilization out there
somewhere maybe multiple multiple
intelligent civilizations that have sent
um whether manned or unmanned craft here
you think well if that were true
kind of evidence will we have of it
and and uh the Skeptics will say well we
don't have any of that evidence well
actually we do though we have a fair
amount of it we would have video we had
a lot of video and it's not all now you
know back in the 60s if we were talking
about UFOs you could say well the video
is grainy and all that that's not true
anymore there's some pretty compelling
video uh and lots of it not just a
little bit there's a lot of video
evidence of
things that are flying around in the sky
in ways that should not be possible
um so we have that
we also now even have scientists and
people that have worked in the
government going on the record and
saying this is what we've seen this is
what we're looking into this is what
we've researched here's the physical
evidence that we have Tucker Carlos was
talking about people that have been
suffer traumatic brain injuries because
of contact with things strange things
that have landed and
so that's all evidence
does it confirm no but it does mean that
if you still are taking the position
that no no none of this is uh this is
none of this is alien and origin that is
actually an irrational position it's an
error it's quite irrational to say to
just definitively declare as I hear many
people do
um
uh absolutely not alien and origin
that's irrational
because we we it's it's just a fact that
there is this evidence
um
and for you to take that position you
would have to just pretend it doesn't
exist or really it would have to be on
your part
it would it would be a it's a position
grounded in your assumption
that there can't possibly be any other
intelligent life in the universe
and I think that is what really explains
almost everyone who says no none of this
is alien in origin absolutely can't be
almost all of them they're saying that
because they refuse to even consider the
possibility that there are any other
intelligent beings in the universe and
that is also an irrational position to
take it just is the universe is vast and
is absolutely loaded with things that we
don't understand and so to sit here and
say I know that this isn't out there I
have seen none of the universe okay I
have seen none of it I I haven't even
seen like it's not even a thimble
compared to the ocean even that it's
like a molecule of the ocean compared to
the entire ocean I have seen that
molecule and because of that molecule I
know for a fact
that there is nothing else out there
um
that's that's basically what you're
declaring and it is it is irrational
so
that's it what are you going to do with
the information it's uh maybe it's scary
for people to think about but
these things are happening
nothing we could do about it
uh let's get to the comment section
[Music]
today
there's someone to think you need a
sweet baby game
tax season is here unfortunately my
accountant swears that the best thing I
did in 2022 was switch to pure talk
instead of paying a fortune to Verizon
at T or T-Mobile you can cut your bill
in half with pure talk Pure Talk offers
unlimited talk text and plenty of data
starting at just 30 bucks a month and
they can save the average family over
900 a year a lot of people think the the
bigger the provider the better the
service well let me fill you in on a
little secret Pure Talk uses the same
network for less there's no contract
there's no hidden fees there's no hassle
you can switch over to Pure Talk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone and your phone number there are
us-based customer service team makes the
the switch really easy for you as well
Pure Talk is so sure that you're going
to love their service they're backing it
up with a 100 money back guarantee your
first month is guaranteed risk free but
you have to go to puretalk.com and to
promo code Walsh to save 50 off your
first month that's puretalk.com promo
code walls Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
all right happy St Patrick's Day uh by
the way very important holiday for
rampant cultural appropriation uh but
it's the kind of cultural appropriation
you're allowed to do because you're
appropriating from Irish people who are
white so it's okay or those are the
rules remember you can celebrate Irish
culture by getting drunk and wearing a
shamrock and you know drinking green
beer and eating Lucky Charms you could
put a pin on that says Kiss Me I'm Irish
and all of that is fine but if you wear
a Native American headdress on Halloween
then that makes you a genocidal racist
um makes sense when you think about it
I'm sorry it makes sense when you don't
think about it actually
some of this is our fault though I'll
admit I mean ours in people's Irish
ancestry because the squeaky wheel gets
the oil as they say and
um and we don't complain about the St
Patrick's Day stuff because we're not uh
Petty and ridiculous and also we have a
sense of humor so it is it is funny we
could laugh about it
and speaking of having a sense of humor
I also why and speaking of Ireland
um I I finally watched a couple nights
ago I watched the movie this is maybe
it's a good movie to watch in St Patrick
if you're looking for a St Patrick's Day
movie there's the uh the the the film uh
banshees of innish year and which uh I
think was you know I think I won a
couple of Academy Awards who cares but
it was nominated for some stuff and uh I
have to say
based on the description of this film I
wasn't very excited about watching it
but a couple people that I who's
opinions I value recommended it and so I
decided to watch it
and I should have watched it you know
when it first came out I I should have
been first in line to see this film at
the in the theaters because it it
resonated with me on such a deep and
personal level because the film at least
on the surface level now there's a lot
of symbolism going on and all that but
uh plenty of metaphor but on the surface
it is really a movie
about a guy Brendan Gleason who hates
small talk so much
that he will chop off his own fingers to
avoid it that's really the movie he
doesn't he's tired of pointless small
talk and he starts amputating his own
fingers in protest to try to get this
other guy to stop talking to him because
he finds that the conversation that
uninteresting
and uh
on that kind of service level I've I've
never found a movie more relatable it's
like it's two and a half hours of a guy
trying to avoid small talk and going to
increasingly desperate legs to avoid it
I found it to be uh
quite powerful so something worth
watching all right
uh bad Mr Frosty says when you Google
your name and the whole cast of The
Daily wire is what comes up talking
against you talking about Dylan now you
know it's time to subscribe to daily
wire Plus
yeah I mean what is that that maybe
tells you all you need to know did Dylan
Mulvaney did his 365 celebration and he
wanted uh villains he wanted the
villains for his for his Big Show and uh
he chose
the entire cast of The Daily wire
um as the as the villains and nobody
else in in conservative media was just
us
um
Denise says
the best thing we could do is not repeat
this individual's name ever and not
share its image across the media's vast
ocean
the talking again about Dil Mulvaney and
yeah I I
understand that argument and uh but I
would also say that that has been the
conservative argument
um
about all this stuff for years and it
hasn't really worked out that way
you know I can remember back
think about when Bruce Jenner came out
as Caitlyn Jenner
and was celebrated as woman of the year
and all that and when that happened back
whenever that was in 2015 or something
and it was the same thing you know I was
talking about that and I was uh I was
very vocally opposed to
Bruce Jenner being accepted by society
as a woman I was very opposed to it and
what I heard from many conservatives was
well let's just not give any attention
to this person they just want attention
let's not give them attention and if we
don't give attention it'll go away well
how did that work out
like how did that strategy or say well
let's not pay attention to this yeah
they're taking a man and celebrating him
as a woman let's not pay attention it's
a trend it's just there's attention
starved
how did that work out for us
has that strategy of ignoring
these sorts of things has that proven to
be effective
now if if we don't oppose this okay but
Dylan Mulvaney that he's he is being
taken he's been selected by the powers
that be as you know there's a reason
he's got all the corporate sponsorships
and everything behind them there's a
reason why he could afford to throw a
big bash at the Rockefeller Center
um he's got money behind him from all
these corporate sponsorships and
everything else so they have Taylor the
cultural Elites the cultural powers that
be have taken this guy and said he's
going to be our new mascot
um he's going to be our our vehicle for
you know getting the stuff out into the
masses and making it appealing and
acceptable and mainstreaming it
so if I don't talk about it and the
other people with daily wire don't talk
about it and we decide to ignore it do
you think that like what's gonna happen
meaning all the corporate sponsorships
are going to go away
do you think the left's gonna say oh
okay we're not interested in it anymore
no then then he's just running unopposed
no then they will continue their
campaign of normalizing this stuff and
it will be a campaign that runs
unopposed
the campaign is happening regardless
thank you
okay it's like it's like a think of an
actual political campaign somebody's
running for office are you going to stop
him from
um being elected to that office by
making sure that no one runs against him
it's the same sort of thing
uh Mary Smith says I'm Matt
um Matt the issue is that women get paid
approximately 30 percent less than men
doing the exact same job I worked as a
scientist in big Pharma and no one ever
discusses salary but after I left and
compared salaries with former colleagues
it was really infuriating to realize
this was true and by the way I worked
harder was smarter than my male
counterparts but I was not able to
schmooze on golf courses shoot the
over beers at their clubs or talk sports
over lunch
male bonding goes a long way to
determine compensation in Corporate
America well Mary first of all I'll tell
you that you're you're not the first
person who uh feels as though they're
they're being under compensated at work
or that they're more talented or you
know better qualified than colleagues or
making more money this is a complaint of
I don't know maybe approximately 99 of
all people in the working in the
workplace men and women alike
but it doesn't necessarily reflect the
reality okay so you think
that you were better qualified you
worked harder you were more skilled than
the people that were working making more
than you and in order to
um explain that to yourself like explain
this disparity you came up with this
story about sexism and how you weren't
able to go to the golf course and all
the rest of it
um maybe that story is true
but there's no reason to assume that it
is
because it is again it's a story that
you've told yourself to explain why you
made less money
so rather than looking at antidote
anecdotes let's look at the actual
statistics
and the actual statistics are this this
is what the data says
um the 30 you know the women make 30
make 70 cents on the dollar whatever I
think now it's up to 82 cents they say
um so women make 82 cents on the on the
dollar for every man for every dollar
that a man earns
that statistic comes from as we've been
talking about a uh just a one-to-one
comparison grouping all women and all
men together and comparing their
salaries uh without taking into account
anything else when you don't control for
any other factors that's what you come
up with and so it is a meaningless
statistic now when you actually do
factor in
um
industry job type hours worked
experience level
over you know over time all that kind of
stuff when you factor all of that in
here's what you come up with
and I'm getting this from the website
payscale.com and they've uh they've
compiled all the information about this
and here's what they say the controlled
gender pay Gap is 99 Cents for every one
dollar a man makes
that's the pay Gap one penny between
when when we control for all these
factors
one penny between the woman and the man
which is to say the gender pay Gap
doesn't exist because one penny is a
rounding error that is margin of error
it doesn't statistically it doesn't
exist
and and this by the way this is from a
source that is not a right-wing Source
like they they are reporting this but
then also claiming that uh there is
still a gender pay Gap because it goes
on in the same report to say
um although 99 Cents may seem very close
to a dollar small differences in
earnings on the dollar can compound over
the course of a lifetime the gender pay
Gap should be zero it is not zero so
they're still trying to pretend they are
biased in favor of trying to uh you know
create a gender pay gap or pretend that
there is one and that's why they're
pretending that one penny still
constitutes uh a problem
when it doesn't because again
statistically it is a its margin of
error and it's also it just it's not
it's it's not possible that you would
control for all these factors and then
make this comparison and they would be
exactly the same
that doesn't happen in real life
so it's effectively the same and that's
what the data tells us
now in addition to me the daily wire has
a couple other hosts you may have heard
of one of them is uh named Ben Shapiro
you might know something about him well
this Ben guy who it turns out is
actually pretty smart and interesting
just premiered the second season of his
show the search and his first guest is
actor comedian and eccentric British man
Russell Brand here's a teaser of their
episode check it out Ben I can smell
weed right now right now and we're gonna
just sit here
Ben there's
an instant in good oh
let me think about that for a couple of
months give me the towel much because if
it's not in there
I
I'm 20 years clean I don't think this is
how it's gonna fall off the wagon I've
been with Bill Mark and that was even
Rogan
man Shapiro and it takes me down for
God's sake
laughs
[Music]
well if you haven't seen the search yet
you should it's not an interview show it
is a conversation show there is a
difference that you'll see when you
watch this show the episodes are
unscripted they're loose they're always
entertaining plus Ben has some a great
guests in store for this season
including a sit down with Megan Kelly as
well to watch the now streaming episode
with Russell Brand become a daily wire
plus member today you'll get exclusive
access to the search plus all daily wire
plus hit shows and movies including my
personal favorite film what is a woman
you can join today and check out the
search by going to dailywireplus.com now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well it's still pretty early but we
already have a candidate for the dumbest
internet controversy of the year and it
all began as usually does with a tweet a
tweet that countless news articles have
described as mean offensive sexist very
very bad a tweet which has led to
thousands upon thousands of people
expressing their outrage while jumping
on an internet dog pile that has lasted
for days now a tweet that's that's
provoked reactions from members of the
media from celebrities uh even for
people who who aren't mentally ill as
well so what was this tweet
what was this outrageous Unthinkable
calamitous tweet which will live
eternally in infamy this tweet that will
have monuments built to it so that
Generations can come and mourn together
and remember the tweet and Lament The
tweet
well here is the Tweet get ready for it
it was posted by journalist uh Lachlan
Markey a couple of days ago and here's
what it said
quote
the tragedy of the White Stripes is how
great they would have been with a half
decent drummer yeah yeah I've heard all
the but it's a carefully crafted sound
man takes I'm sorry Meg white was
terrible and no band is better for
having percussion
that's it that's the whole thing Lachlan
posted an opinion about an early 2000s
rock band which he said uh didn't he
didn't have a good drummer he didn't
like the drummer he said the drummer of
a band that broke up over a decade ago
was terrible and that is what caused
Mass outrage this is what prompted not
one think piece but many just the first
page of Google News results has 10
articles about this opinion from major
media Outlets all condemning it as wrong
offensive of course misogynistic
other musicians like Quest Love From The
Roots have joined in to voice their
disapproval Questlove responded quote
I try to leave troll views alone but
this right here is out of line AF
actually what is wrong with music is
people choking the life out of music
like an Instagram filter trying to reach
a high of Music Perfection that doesn't
even serve the song or music
out of line he says it is out of line to
dislike the drummer from The White
Stripes you are not allowed to dislike
her you have to like her drumming
it is entirely out of bounds to have any
other opinion about her drumming skills
this is also apparently the opinion of
Jack White of course the former lead
singer of White Stripes who responded to
the controversy with a lengthy poem that
he wrote as a as a tribute to Meg White
yes that's correct they they are
memorializing her as if the Tweet
literally killed her they're writing
poems in tribute to her because someone
criticized her drumming on Twitter so
this is what Jack White posted on
Instagram he posted quote
to be born in another time any era but
our own would have been fine 100 years
from now a thousand years from now some
other distant different time one without
demons cowards and vampires Out For
Blood one with the positive inspiration
to Foster what is good an empty field
where no tall red poppies are cut down
where we could lay all day every day on
the warm and subtle ground and know just
what to say and what to play to conjure
our own sounds and be one with the
others all around us and even still the
ones who came before and help ourselves
to all their love and pass it on again
once more to have Bliss upon Bliss upon
Bliss to be without fear negativity or
pain and to get up every morning and be
happy
to do it all again
just to remind you that is a poem
written in response to one random guy
who said Meg white wasn't a good drummer
he is the demon coward and vampire out
for blood in this poem he is the source
of fear negativity and pain
and if you think that is just a tad
melodramatic wait until you hear
lachlan's inevitable apology tweet which
we knew was going to happen actually
it's more like an apology essay now
before we read it you know if it were me
and and yes I'm uh I'm a uh uh a
contrarian uh a-hole I know that
but if I had voiced a music opinion that
prompted Jack White to write a tearful
poem
I would think that the whole thing was
absolutely great it'd be the greatest
thing ever and Incredibly funny of
course I'd probably respond by randomly
insulting other musicians just to see if
I could get more of them to write
retaliatory poems
I'd start thinking even bigger actually
maybe if I bullied enough rock stars
eventually they'd all band together and
record a kind of We Are the World type
charity single to stand up against my
hate that's what I would do that's my
dream
but Lachlan adopted the opposite
strategy and instead of enjoying this
hilarious moment he ran away in fear he
deleted the offending tweet he locked
down his Twitter account and he posted
this apology quote by now you've
probably seen an ill-advised and since
deleted tweet that I sent out yesterday
about the white stripes and Meg white it
was an over-the-top take on the White
Stripes and white as a drummer and it
was let's face it just truly awful in
every way Petty obnoxious just plain
wrong I don't know if Meg white herself
saw that tweet I hope not because I
imagine it wouldn't feel great to see a
stranger dumping on you like that so to
Meg white I am sorry really and to women
in music the music business generally
who I think are disproportionately
subject to this sort of
I am sorry to have fed that as well I'm
really going to try to be more
thoughtful in the future both on here
and off I've been thinking to myself as
all this again completely Justified hate
comes in over the last 24 hours why did
I actually write that it's not what I
really think and I like to think I'm not
well it made me out to be or at least I
try not to be I think the answer in part
is that the sort of vicious sniping is
something that we as online folks tend
to reward with eyes and clicks and I
think I got caught up in that implicit
incentive structure with a needlessly
inflammatory downright mean and most
importantly false take
well um that is also embarrassing that I
felt secondhand shame just from reading
it out loud
I mean we have seen some truly pathetic
groveling public apologies in the past
many of them
but this one manages to sync to new
depths of self-degradation
he is pretending now that his tweet
about a band that existed 20 years ago
was some kind of
trolling intentionally inflammatory hot
take
you know as if he wrote that tweet about
Meg white as a drummer thinking that it
would attract reactions from millions of
people
but of course that's not the case it was
just an innocuous opinion that was not
intended to be the subject of a
week-long national discourse
Meg white is a millionaire and a former
rock star she's not a victim she's not a
victim because some dude on Twitter
doesn't like her drumming
all musicians encounter criticism they
have to they have to be able to deal
with it they are not damsels in distress
actually the person being bullied here
is Lachlan he's the one being targeted
and harassed by thousands of rabid
hyenas who are enraged for reasons that
they can't even explain
but Lachlan doesn't have the balls to
make this point in his own defense which
means that all of my sympathy Forum of
course evaporates
most pathetic while Lachlan is now
confessing that the opinion he held up
till three days ago about Meg White's
drumming is now wrong
he's been convinced that his opinion was
wrong how was he convinced well because
lots of people were upset about the
opinion but how does that work exactly
you didn't like her as a drummer you
said you didn't like her as a drummer a
bunch of people cried about it and now
you do like her as a drummer
their hurt feelings convinced you that
your analysis of her artistic talents
was incorrect
how does that work
and of course just to make matters more
ridiculous the opinion that Lachlan
articulated about Meg white used to be
widely shared by nearly everyone because
in fact Meg white isn't a great drummer
it was never controversial to say that
until everyone arbitrarily decided that
it is controversial in fact many of the
media Outlets that are now valiantly
defending Meg White
used to publish reviews ripping her to
shreds for example Pitchfork condemned
lachlan's tweet as a a bad take
but back in 2003 here's what they wrote
in a review for The White Stripes album
elephant this is what they wrote quoting
now quote
the naivete of Meg's playing deflates
any big rock aspirations Meg's pancake
handed drumming drips solvent over the
whole experiment
now just to clarify here pancake handed
drumming is not meant as a compliment in
fact it's a pretty clever insult and
this is the kind of fun and vivid
imagery we used to get from music and
film critics before it was decided the
last thing a Critic should ever do is
engage in you know actual criticism
but this is not a surprise really I mean
there are many many widely held beliefs
and opinions from 20 years ago that are
now treated as utterly shocking
opinions about Meg White's drumming
chops are the least of it
but this is how the game is played now
opinions no matter how innocuous or
valid or or both you know are treated
like like war crimes at least some
opinions right because the rules are
meant to be arbitrary there's always
this element of Simon says to it after
all it's not as though we live in an era
of niceness where everyone is expected
to be nice to each other and polite and
gentle with their wording there's still
plenty of viciousness to go around
we live in a culture that is in many
ways far nastier far more negative far
uglier far more cruel than it was 20
years ago back when music critics
delighted in finding creative ways to
insult rock stars
it's just that the cruelty could only be
sent in certain directions at people who
are not accepted members of assigned
victim groups and if anyone commits the
ultimate sin of wrong think
then there's essentially nothing you can
say or do to him that would be
considered overboard
but Meg white though A Millionaire
musician can claim membership in a
recognized victim group as a woman which
means that any criticism of her is a
human rights violation
these are the rules now and they are
insane
which is why the cancel mob coming after
Lachlan is canceled but since he bowed
and apologized to the Mob Lachlan
himself is also I must say today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]